[Music]
hi rob lowe this is susan from
libertyville illinois
love love love your podcast i've
literally been listening
since the very beginning and it has been
a big time lifesaver during all of kovid
i've also enjoyed your books very much
and i was wondering
if you've ever considered doing any
fictional writing with all of your
hollywood history and experiences that
could be quite interesting
and i would read it for sure
thank you so much rob lowe love you and
i'll keep listening
oh thank you for your support
i mean really without people like you
then this whole thing doesn't happen and
and i'm i'm super appreciative
of your call and your support and the
fact that you like my books i love
writing them
they they do take a lot of time i have
thought about writing um fiction and i
have a couple ideas floating around
um not the least of which is really
talking about what malibu
california was like in 19 in the
mid-1970s
and that's sort of my great
project that i'm just ruminating and one
thing i've learned is an idea will
happen when it's time
and
you can force it you can start it you
can stop it but as long as you're
committed to it and thinking about it
when the time is right it's gonna happen
um and i i just have sort of confidence
in that i don't know when it'll be but
but that feels like the thing i would
like to write and probably will at some
point but thank you thank you for the
call thanks for listening